we're told suppose that 15% of the 1750
students at a school have experienced
extreme levels of stress during the past
month a high school newspaper doesn't
know this figure but they are curious
what it is so they decide to ask us a
simple random sample of 160 students if
they have experienced extreme levels of
stress during the past month
subsequently
they find that 10% of the sample replied
yes to the question assuming the true
proportion is 15% which they tell us up
here they say 15% of the population of
the seventeen hundred and fifty students
actually have experienced extreme levels
of stress during the past month so that
is the true proportion so let me just
write that the true proportion for our
population is 0.15 what is the
approximate probability that more than
10% of the sample would report that they
experienced extreme levels of stress
during the past month so pause this
video and see if you can answer it on
your own and there are four choices here
I'll scroll down a little bit and see if
you can answer this on your own so the
way that we're going to tackle this is
we're going to think about the sampling
distribution of our sample proportions
and first we're going to say well is
this sampling distribution approximately
normal is it approximately normal and if
it is then we can use its mean and
standard deviation and create a normal
distribution that has that same mean and
standard deviation in order to
approximate the probability that they're
asking for so for the first this first
part how do we decide this well the rule
of thumb we have here and it is a rule
of thumb is that if we take our sample
size times our population proportion and
that is greater than or equal to 10 and
our sample size times 1 minus our
population proportion is greater than or
equal to 10 then if both of these are
true then our sampling distribution of
our sample proportions is going
be approximately normal so in this case
the newspaper is asking 160 students
that's the sample size so 160 the true
population proportion is 0.15 and that
needs to be greater than or equal to 10
and so let's see this is going to be 16
plus 8 which is 24 and 24 is indeed
greater than or equal to 10 so that
checks out and then if I take our sample
size times 1 minus P well 1 minus 1500s
is going to be 85 hundredths and this is
definitely going to be greater than or
equal to 10 let's see this is going to
be 24 less than 160 so this is going to
be 136 which is way larger than 10 so
that checks out and so the sampling
distribution of our sample proportions
is approximately going to be normal and
so what is the mean and standard
deviation of our sampling distribution
so the mean of our sampling distribution
is just going to be our population
proportion we've seen that in other
videos which is equal to 0.15 and our
standard deviation of our sampling
distribution of our sample proportions
is going to be equal to the square root
of P times 1 minus P over N which is
equal to the square root of 0.15 times
0.85 all of that over our sample size
160 so now let's get our calculator out
so I'm going to take the square root of
0.15 times 0.85 divided by 160 let me
close those parentheses and so what is
this going to give me so it's going to
give me approximately 0.028 and I'll go
to the thousands place here so this is
approximately zero point zero two eight
this is going to be approximately a
normal distribution so you could draw
your classic bell curve for a
normal distribution so something like
this and our normal distribution is
going to have a mean it's going to have
a mean right over here of so this is the
mean of our sampling distribution so
this is going to be equal to the same
thing as our population proportion 0.15
and we also know that our standard
deviation here is going to be
approximately equal to zero point zero
two eight and what we want to know is
what is the approximate probability that
more than 10% of the sample would report
that they experienced extreme levels of
stress during the past month so we could
say that 10% would be right over here
I'll say zero point one zero and so the
probability that in a sample of 160 you
get a proportion for that sample a
sample proportion that is larger than
10% would be this area right over here
so this right over here would be the
probability that your sample proportion
is greater than they say is more than
10% is more than 0.1 I could write one
zero just like that and then to
calculate it I can get out our
calculator again so here I'm gonna go to
my distribution menu right over there
and then I'm going to do a normal
cumulative distribution function so let
me click enter there and so what is my
lower bound
well my lower bound is ten percent zero
point one what is my upper bound well
we'll just make this one because that is
the highest proportion you could have
for a sampling distribution of sample
proportions now what is our mean well we
already know that's 0.15 what is the
standard deviation of our sampling
distribution
well it's approximately zero point zero
to eight and then I can click enter and
if you're taking an AP exam you actually
should write this you should say you
should tell the graders what you're
actually typing in in your normal CDF
function but if we click enter right
over here and then enter there we have
it it's approximately 96% so this is
approximately zero point nine six and
not out of our choices it would be this
one right over here if you're taking
this on the AP exam you would say that
called
called normal normal CDF where you have
your lower bound lower bound and you
would put in your zero point one zero
you would say that use an upper bound
upper bound of one you would say that
you gave a mean of 0.15 and then you
gave a standard deviation of 0.02 a just
so people know that you knew what you
were doing but hopefully this is helpful